it was freaky what I lived through last
night and it may happen again tonight
doctor says may happen like five eight
times Chris Cuomo is opening up about
the scary symptoms he's had since
testing positive for the corona virus I
tested positive scare yes as you might
imagine but better me than you let's use
this example of me having it as proof
that you can get it - god forbid the 49
year old CNN anchor announced Tuesday
that he tested positive for koban 19 but
he's still working while he's under
quarantine from his wife and three kids
streaming his show from his basement
this virus came at me I've never seen
anything like it okay
on Wednesday Chris revealed that after
testing positive his symptoms took a
turn for the worse that night so yeah
I've had a fever you've had a fever but
102 103 103 Plus that wouldn't quit and
it was like somebody was beating me like
a pinata
Chris said that it got so bad that he
actually hallucinate 'add and thought
that he was talking to his dad who died
in 2015 I was shivering so much I
chipped my tooth so the Sun comes up I'm
awake I was up all night was wrong I'm
telling you I was hallucinating I said
my dad was talking to me I was seeing
people from college people I haven't
seen it forever it was freaky what I
lived through last night and it may
happen again
tonight doctor says it may happen like
five eight times you know I get it now
and if you match that with chest
constriction of people can't breathe I
totally get why we're losing so many
people and why our hospitals are so
crowded but on the upside Chris said
that his wife Christina and their kids
have all tested negative for the virus
their wife I my kids thank God didn't
have it look how lucky I got here and
even with that high fever Chris is
staying in relatively good spirits the
news anchor popped into his brother and
the governor of New York Andrew Cuomo's
briefing and had a good family laugh
obviously the fever has affected your
mental capacity yep of course Chris's
diagnosis had a big impact not only on
his older bro who tweeted that Chris was
his best friend but also on his
coworkers sorry I said I wasn't gonna do
this Jesus on Tuesday CNN's Don Lemon
broke down in tears talking about
Chris's health and Chris and I are
really good friends we live near each
other and so when I walk into work every
day I have to walk by where Chris is so
I usually like go to his office and I
say you know and what's doing sometimes
I bring the dogs and we just say hello
anyway he's just not here
[Music]